la peur et l'angoissé sont des compagnes
faire entendre raison
j'aurais tant voulu aimer cette fin de
chanson et chacun tensions subies stoner
alors qu'ils silencieux c'est
c'est un titre qui fait réfléchir déjà
dans le sens où un oxymore qui comprend
pas et ça met en avant des personnes qui
souffrent
travers des situations mes compagnons
en l'occurrence là on parle de femmes
sont généralement qui est souffre de
violence musicale de viol d'agression
kim et moi même j'ai déjà puis une
expérience les avis de ceux là j'ai pu
moi-même traverse à cette situation et
puis par daumier et c'est aujourd'hui
nous sommes le premier outil que c'était
tout c'est un moyen pour partager les
autres
mon expérience et pouvoir aider d'autres
personnes
ya beaucoup de femmes messieurs je
connais tous vécu ce genre de choses là
une personnellement qui s'était confié à
moi c'était une expérience qui m'a
vraiment touché dans le sens où on se
connaissait pas forcément mais s'est
confié à moyen terme a confié que voilà
allait subi une tentative de viol et ça
a expliqué beaucoup de choses se
disaient n'importe c